hey i'm austin abrams i play dad hi my
name is midori francis
and i play lily so my name is dante
brown and i play boom
hi i'm troy iwata and i play langston
yeah and we're gonna
take a buzzfeed quiz to figure out which
dash and lily character
we are
let's start off with some introspection
which word best describes you at this
very moment
there's cheeky chill copacetic and
confident
what is copacetic i have to be
completely honest i don't know what it
means either and that makes me want to
pick it but
knowing my luck is going to mean like
poop or something i'm picking
cheeky as well i think i'm going to be
cheeky too
i'm picking coffee no you know what i'm
going to be confident yeah i'm going to
be confident
an iconic new york city landmark to
spend the day the strand bookstore
the met central park grand central
station who's going to spend the whole
day at grand central station
somebody who missed their train and
loves the food at the amazing
restaurants there
i'm going to the met yeah i'm going to
the bed i'm just picking
that i'm going to go to central park
please call me on grand
station i did i sold you they have
sunglasses they have a smoothie shop
they have a great uh panini place
yeah i'm just gonna take your apparel
select another nyc
bass show to bench watch gossip girls
effectively and law and order special
difference
unit i'm picking law order oh you're
picking law and order yeah
it's a big commitment i'm doing guys i
like broad city better but i feel like i
want to binge sex in the city right now
i
pick you know broad city it seems fun
which book are you reading in the corner
of your fave
coffee shop from the mixed up files of
mrs basiley frankweiler
the chronicles of narnia the lion witch
in the wardrobe alice's adventures in
wonderland or brave new world
i'm gonna read brave new worlds i'm
going to chronicles of narnia
i'm doing alice in wonderland because
i've never really yet i will just see
what that's about i'd say brave new
world
holiday beverage looks the most tasty
mulled wine eggnog potato or pepperoni
i'm doing peppermint hot never mind
chocolate looks good
i think i need a hot toddy right now so
i'm gonna pick out peppermint hot
chocolate
pick something red from dash and lily
the cinderella boot
the do you dare notebook the lily
embossed
santa hat the perfect mochi perfect
mochi is more pink i'm gonna pick it
i'm gonna pick the hat with my name on
it yeah but maybe the mochi you know you
can eat that
yo you can eat it can you eat it yeah
i'm gonna what else can you do
finally because why not pick a jonas
brother song
to jam out to like it's christmas
sucker love bug year 3000 i pick you up
i pick like it's christmas i'm picking
sucker because i like that
music video all their wives look great
yeah
[Music]
guys i'm so happy that i got lily i got
lily i'm so worried
they're gonna dance you got dash yeah
since you got dash you're a
self-proclaimed loner who was a tad bit
cynical than most but beneath that
tattered peacoat is a capable person who
will go to the ends of the earth or you
know across a
new york city tomorrow the ones they
love i got lily
i really didn't think i was gonna get it
you radiate positive vibes and christmas
spirit
all year round your infectious energy
can put a smile on the grumpiest of teen
boys
austin the jonas brothers said it best
after all
you make every day feel like it's
christmas okay so the character that i
got is
boomer you're an extremely loyal friend
who wants the best
for those in your life whether it be
helping a friend come out of their shell
or just providing the pizza that's 100
i got lily i'm thrilled that everybody
got their own character except for me
it says that i really did my character
work well and i'm really excited for the
show to come out
you